pledging allegiance to the taliban
tribesmen dignitaries and members of the
former government in kandahar the
birthplace of the taliban and its seat
of power
a show of unity at a delicate moment for
the group that swept into the capital
last month
but the taliban is now denying rumors of
a possible power struggle and in
fighting among its senior leadership
reports also suggested deputy prime
minister mullah abdelgani brother was
sidelined as the rumors spread the
taliban dispatched one of its officials
anas haqqani with one message to convey
the taliban is more united than ever
mullah brother later appeared himself in
a video explaining why he hasn't been
seen in public for the last few days
i was travelling from kabul so i had no
access to the media in order to reject
this news we assure the afghanistan
nation mujahideen elders and youth not
to worry there's no reason to worry
but many aflans are worried
they fear a prolonged leadership crisis
that may create more poverty and
uncertainty
in the past there was peace and people
had their jobs now people are hungry and
many are anxious about what may happen
next
i joined at the taliban three years ago
my hopes for a prosperous and peaceful
afghanistan this is my biggest wish as
winter approaches tens of thousands of
people have fled their homes recently we
need food
shelter and stoves
the u.n has warned the country may face
a severe humanitarian situation if aid
does not arrive soon
the taliban is now back in power but its
challenges are far from over
the group is facing mounting pressure to
form an inclusive government and is
desperate for international recognition
and financial assistance at a moment
when two-thirds of the afghans need help
al-jazeera kabul